Operating a CDN presents many different challenges. And
the underlying goal is to replicate content on
many servers. So that the content is replicated
close to the clients. Yet this leaves many open
questions. Including how to replicate the content. Where
it should be replicated, how clients should find
the replicated content, how to choose the appropriate
server replica, or cache, for a particular client, and
how to direct clients towards the appropriate replica once it's
selected. This problem is commonly known as server selection, and this
problem is sometimes called content routing. Let's take a look
at each of these problems in a little bit more detail.